well from our perspective um the first
thing that needs to be addressed is
taking care of the troops we've got a
lot of men and women that bless their
hearts are doing dangerous work for the
United States to defend freedom and I
think it's important that we make sure
that they have the latest technology
you've heard about reset or recharge
what those words mean is that some of
our some of our armed service personnel
particularly those in conflict have used
up some of their equipment they don't
have all the modern and all the latest
of the equipment that they need and I
think it's important that we make sure
that they have the latest technology and
the best equipment to be able to
position appropriately around the world
so taking care of the troops and making
sure that they're recharged with
equipment you know the second that the
second policy you know I would have to
say and this gets somewhat political is
that we have to understand the military
and the military industrial component
very very well before we get involved in
future conflicts and it's not to say
that we don't do the very best job we
can but obviously um you know we got
into a rock it's going to be hard to get
out of a rock both from a political
standpoint a sociological standpoint and
so understanding these components of the
the of the of the foreign policy
equation I think are very very important
the other thing I think we we we have to
learn as Americans and I on so i would
offer this advice to our administration
and that is we are a participant in a
broad global political network and i
think it's very very important for us to
make sure that we bring along the the
other key global constituents of that
network as we think about foreign policy
this is a change for the United States
it's obviously very complex to think
through but nonetheless I think if we
can advance together with our arm you
know a lot arms locked together with
other global partners with respect to
foreign policy that would ultimately be
beneficial
there were a few that there were a you
know some highlighted examples of
something like timecard charging or you
know some events which occurred that I
think were somewhat surgical in nature
and in the grand scheme of things were
relatively small and unfortunately I
believe that the defense industry was
painted unfairly with respect to what
you refer to as a disequilibrium I think
it's important to recognize that the
defense industry is comprised of a very
very strongly dedicated patriotic group
of people many of our companies thirty
forty percent of them are ex-military
members on the in the defense private
sector today and you know the this is an
industry that not only is doing very
very essential things for the US defense
of freedom for everything that we have
in this country but doing so things in a
very compliant and a very socially
responsible and philanthropic way and so
when you look at the defense industry in
the aggregate it's a wonderful industry
it's populated with a great group of
high quality high character individuals
and it has a consequence I would like to
see more of a positive a positive brush
painted over this industry because it
because this is the industry that's
creating the technology and the know-how
to allow the United States to operate as
effectively as it does
you